femme like you était le deuxième single
le plus vendu en france en 2004 c'est un
énorme carton jaune à maroua le premier
alors ben justement la question c'était
quoi le premier le premier premier
single vendu en france en 2004 obsession
obsession de avant toi des deux zones
rurales et aux deux tragédies ou pâtira
journaux partir à jour son retour
alors à votre avis et quattro du tout
autant c'est quoi cabaret droit que
c'était aux zones au sol aux zones
c'était ses savoirs et pêchu
[Applaudissements]
à
j'adore
j'étais en tournée mais j'étais encore
sans fin pour faire la promotion de fin
de la q1 et je me souviens que mon label
m'avait appelé pour dire que c'était une
autre époque et mon label m'appelle et
me dit qu on est enfin passé devant
ozone numéro 1 du top et on vend des
150000 single par semaine et non non
c'est incroyable maintenant tu as un
disque d'or dont on dit ça y est quoi
c'est vrai c'est un truc de deux russes
et il ose on embrasse d'ailleurs 11n
alors ils adorent et cm1 roissy ont été
comme ça je sais pas du tout qui sait ah
oui bah je sais oui merci
celle fait l'eurovision celle ci après
le pensionnat de chavagnes m6 a mis à
l'antenne le pensionnat de sarlat le
pensionnat de prêt court le pensionnat
de saint cyr ou la maison de retraite
morini-bosc camaro puisque c'est l'année
2004 s'est tuée je suis maxime kenny
dans le pensionnat et ouais et que ce
soit dans le souk pensionnat de
chavagnes ou celui de salah on a eu
droit à monsieur navarro oui je me
rappelle et j'adorais moi j'adorais
cette chanson à l'époque et avait repris
c'était adieu monsieur le professeur et
oui ça te tais des fois je sais plus on
a faim il ya un mec qui lui ressemble et
où c'est pas un truc comme ça je dis une
connerie qui a regardé son pétage de
câble face à un pensionnaire je
regardais ça fait même s'il y avait
cette musique si vous avez un petit peu
répond bien aux ailes bihorel ce matin
et à mademoiselle andré du tout cette
sortie vous avez reconnu votre état
le vélo c'est qu'elle est bonne raison
c'est votre professeur de chant vient
d'enjoindre au sol et vous c'est qu'elle
avait raison alors pour ces derniers la
liberté j'adore je vous le met un jour
ici je travaille à croisions des raies
dans mon incroyable fiancé qualité le
prénom de la femme piégée par laurent
ournac emeline céline adeline où
abdelkader c'est camaro a compris ou
d'arrêts camaro auditeurs et vendu des
disques tu dis quoi vous allez droit et
date d'isabelle morini-bosc moi je dis
là c'est bah merci l'a6 et adeline
exactement on se rappelle de sa mon
incroyable fiancé longue exceptionnel ça
ça semble des plus grandes émissions
avec 13 millions donnés par ailleurs 13
millions et un carton cet appel ne soit
pas michel 13 mais pas vraiment alors
mon incroyable fiancé en fait dans cette
émission laurent ournac adeline devait
faire comme s'ils étaient en couple et
convaincre leurs parents sauf quatre
lignes ne savais pas que laurent était
un comédien
on va avoir une scène où il peine au
chaud pendant kathleen line crack en
interview regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là je l'entends et réglementant demain
je vais rencontrer quelqu'un
[Musique]
peut-être bien tombée amoureuse avec lui
il est très très loin mon rêve il est
parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
très forte à vous en rappelez
certainement que des questions aussi sur
les années 2004 avant de poser à la
question regardez cet extrait culte de
pop star avec bruno vandelli harbour il
va nous faire regarder ça c'est toujours
une d'arcari corps quadricolor pascal
picq accueillir quatre couleurs et sont
à deux couleurs quadricolor ça va mal
c'est joli ça a pas mal c'est la place
que j'ai eu il ya deux semaines j'ai
rien osé dire si je me dire ah ben oui
ça le fait grave parce que ça ne termine
que tout le monde connaît qui se dire en
anglais en camions espagnols en france
et dans toutes les langues et de la
couleur jeter quelques voix dans sa tête
oh ouais il dit ça en de la merde c'est
jamais ap quadricolor le devoir et à
quel est le nom du groupe vainqueur de
la saison de popstars the mess whatfor
linkup ouzou chômeurs l'a26 nom vous dit
quoi
[Musique]
non attention à la marche est ouest en
2004 aussi attention à la marche
lorsque jean-luc pose une question
coquine on entend le titre you fuck my
lai et aux assauts firth mamma smiling
barry white sous les sunlights des uv de
bernard montiel joe cocker ou with or
without you de la question qu est la
question
regardez mari
contre un garçon en boîte ouais et donc
je les ai revus après très bien tout va
bien donc le garçon hyper beau hyper
sharma que c'était bien et puis arrivés
eux au moment oui oui
et c'est tromper
ils devaient souvent des problèmes de
vue
[Musique]
donc après j'ai repoussé poussé la ville
à paris
et alors il voulait revenir il voulait
revenir
moi j'ai dit que c'était pas possible ce
n'est pas possible
surtout nommé encore encore d'autres est
l'homme parfait de gardel
alors
ils ont des missions que la réponse est
normal ce qu'on voulait c'était voir
jean luc reichmann qui fait la question
conne
vous la verrez demain merci c'est comme
ça enregistrés ça aujourd'hui l'heure
est coupé par à 12h30
paf a cédé au bout de deux arrivées pas
mal de fois les chéris